hey I'll ask you this what did you think
after the fourth round when she said I'm
done and her coach is like no you're not
done you get back in there you get back
in there you're gonna you know power
through you're gonna what do you think
of that it's wrong yeah and I'm telling
it's wrong for this we as fans as Humes
we put way way too much emphasis on the
importance of a fight okay
now it's a it's a fight and it's
important to that fighter as they step
into that cage for that you know first
round and it's important for them as
long as they are mentally capable of
enduring what is occurring because you
know fighters go through evolutions
during the fight they're strong they're
weak you know they're doing well they're
not doing well and once a fighter tells
you I'm done it's gone yeah you're
expecting her let's look at what you
really have she lost four rounds in a
row okay had she lost four rounds and
the fourth was no Dunkley brutal one her
nose was shadows got crushed blood was
pouring all over the way and you know
again for people to understand let me
break your nose and now let me punch it
again right okay you have no concept
because what I'm telling is you know
during a fight fighters don't feel pain
the way people think because there's
adrenaline and there's all these things
and it's muted you feel things and
sometimes you really start to feel him
and as soon as you really start to feel
him you start to lose really bad yeah
and in that situation where she had lost
four rounds badly okay so what's gonna
happen in the fifth you think she's
gonna come out with this homerun shot
okay okay if her mind is still there
maybe then it maybe it maybe can happen
but as soon as she says I'm done I want
out hey it's a fight and did she receive
more damage after that statement in the
fifth round oh yeah
she received more damage and what I'm
telling you is it's like you can you can
have the greatest car in the world
all right you can have you know you
betta you know I'm not a real great car
guy but in a truck this is you know the
Raptor or Ford Raptor truck you can only
crash it into the wall so many times
before it says [ __ ] you I'm done okay
and it's not now no longer a nice truck
it's a piece of [ __ ] it doesn't work
exactly and the real question is how
much damage did you do for the rest of
racquel Penningtons career because she
took extra damage and you never know
when it is Joe and I can tell you I can
I can pick out fights where I can tell
you this is the difference in that
fighter from this fight in that moment
he is no longer the same she is no
longer the same and so as the trainer
what are you there for you are there to
get your fighter ready for the fight
you're there to be the person that's
helping them during the fight in giving
them instructions and telling them how
to attack this person and saying you're
doing this wrong I need you to do this
whatever it's going to be that's your
job you are there to sometimes motivate
them when they start to lose the belief
that I don't know if I can beat this
person and that happens to everybody I
don't I don't know if I can actually
that this person's kicking my ass to be
that persuade your doing fine what I
need you to do is this you get yourself
together be that motivate right but once
the fighter tells you I'm done hey
that's the minds gone it's over
don't put them back out there because
they're not going to perform they're not
gonna do well they can sit there
afterwards and say oh you know I'm glad
that I went out there it didn't change
any what what changed the only thing
that changed was the amount of damage
that she incurred that's it she defended
her coach after the fight mm-hmm you
know but most people would it's fine she
believes in her coach and she said it
was the right decision but uh most
people that watched that said they
should stop the fight
right when she said that and I agree
with you and I think especially when you
dealing with someone as tough as her yes
for Raquel Pennington I'm a giant fan of
hers yes for her to say I'm done like
you got our respect what have you ever
seen her quit never okay now